[Music]
or maybe
we should just realize that what we've
had these past few weeks has been
perfect
and maybe it won't get any better than
this and maybe
we're trying to figure this thing out
because it makes us feel so good to feel
this way and maybe the fact that i'm
leaving in eight hours makes this
far more exciting than it might actually
be
maybe you're seriously the most
depressing girl i've ever met
i know
i have another scenario for you good
i'm in love with you
i apologize for the blunt delivery
but as problematical as this
fact may be i am in love
with you and i'm not feeling this
because
you're leaving and not because it feels
good to feel this way which by the way
it does
or did before you went off like that i
can't
figure out the mathematics of this i
just know
i love you can't believe how many times
i'm saying it
and i never thought i'd feel this way
again so that's pretty phenomenal
and i realize i come with a package deal
three for the price of one and my
package perhaps in the light of day
isn't all that wonderful but i
finally know what i want and that in
itself is a miracle
and what i want is you
[Applause]
all the perfect days
i love christmas wrapping presents and
all that
and then somehow you wind up over
cooking the turkey anyway
done
where'd you learn so much about train
sets oh i read
too much probably it's refreshing
thank you merry christmas
merry christmas
what brings you to cookware it's that
smell to tell you the truth
i can't help it it washed down an
escalator usually i can resist but
oh well please have some probably get
fired over
this did you ever have a smell that
triggers a memory
this smells like my mama's house
thank you
that's incredible incredible
just trying to settle cook with
where'd you become a chef france or
someplace
european or something oh no well i'm not
a chef i've never been to france
i ain't never been further north of
mobile alabama
it's just a hobby something i really
enjoy doing
a hobby i never trained or anything
you gonna train i don't know someday
maybe look i was wondering sometime
[Music]
oh hello
hello um this is my mom
and my dad and uncle tony and my auntie
glenn hi
very nice to meet you and um this is the
prime minister yes we can see that
darling
in there
what about mr sheldrake i'm sending him
a fruitcake every christmas
cut
i love you miss kublic three
queen did you hear what i said ms kublic
i absolutely adore you
shut up and deal
[Music]
my dearest friend if you don't mind
i'd like to join you by your
side where we can
gaze into the stars
[Music]
now and forever
[Music]
see
so you're being deaf oh actually we were
amazed by how little issue the agency
had over the whole hearing thing
uh-huh there's so many more questions
about our history as a couple
and about money this may be a personal
question but do you have a preference
about the child's race
julie i'd like a little black baby
don't you already have a little black
baby can you dig it i'm so sorry i
oh it totally doesn't matter to us
i was just wondering
genie i'm just so excited about having
this shout at all
you're the singer if i sing another boy
but he gives me good night
let me tell you a secret
put it in your heart and keep it
something that i want you to know
do something for me listen to myself
story maybe we'll have something to show
you it's fear that often gets in the way
of its magic i'm sorry
class started an hour ago i'm sorry to
you too
i need to talk to you what are you doing
here
you deserve flowers
i want to be the one that gives you
flowers
i was wrong i'm sorry this is all new
and scary and it's wonderful and
exciting but it's scary
and the thing with austin i'm so sorry i
should have told you
but i love you i'm in love with you
this is not how i saw my life but it's
it's so much
better than anything i could have
imagined
and i want to be with you you'll take me
back
oh hey hi
again yeah from the cleaners right
click yeah right right right from
cleveland
sir buying sweets sweets oh yeah yeah
yeah
i'm getting some some sweets sweets for
your
sweetheart uh no no i i don't have a
sweetheart
you no no no
totally free single
right yes so yeah so you know i was uh
i'm from out of town i was just
walking by i had a little craving for
some um
uh petite fruit jelly beans you know so
i just uh came on in and uh
i sell off supplies and it gets kind of
boring you know you know
what about you um i'm from town
uh single mother with three kids um
and i just bought a stapler well it's
good it's good well so you ever need
anything i'm sure
i i'll need whatever you have how about
this way
i love that you get cold when it's 71
degrees out i love that it takes you an
hour and a half to order a sandwich
i love that you get a little crinkle
above your nose when you're looking at
me like i'm nuts
i love that after i spend a day with you
i can still smell your perfume on my
clothes
and i love that you are the last person
i want to talk to before i go to sleep
at night
and it's not because i'm lonely and it's
not because it's new year's eve
i came here tonight because when you
realize you want to spend the rest of
your life with somebody you want the
rest of your life to start as soon as
possible
[Music]
you see that is
just like you harry you say things like
that and you make it impossible for me
to hate you
and i hate you harry
i really hate you
so
[Music]
you